this is good news everyone share is
going on tour yes I'm going to Australia
New Zealand how did they get so lucky
my manager Zealand no it just kind of
you know what because I went to the
parade up to Mardi Gras right and I had
a great great time and someone said
would you like to come down here and I
said sure and what about the rest of us
okay the last time you were on the show
yes you Toby stop asking stupid
questions that's never going to happen
and now look you are on the road again
well yes because who knew I mean I'm
almost I'm so old who thought that this
would know but I don't have little
weight chin hairs but like some people
[Applause]
now shaved is all right I slapped you
backstage and you said something very
funny and I kept more what it is no can
I would repeat it no nobody expects to
be working at my age are very few women
on tour or women on stage now you know I
think Bette and I are it so I it wasn't
a lie I just didn't think I would be
here so if you're still doing it at 72
72 72 do you have
no I have no number in my head
because it doesn't compute it's like my
mother is 92 and my mother is so cute
and adorable you know and she's she was
the one from the beginning of my life
who said you know you will she said you
won't be the prettiest you won't be the
smartest you won't be the most talented
but you are special and so she has you
know that's what she instilled in me but
she didn't tell me that you would go on
forever
what does him good luck with the tort I
hope it comes here share everybody
[Applause]
[Music]